everything in the world that you can see
feel and touch is made of matter from
water under a bridge to the air you
breathe to that special someone's hand
that you get to hold but we've known
since 1932 that anti-matter exists it's
sort of like the opposite of matter
except in this case opposites are best
not to attract because when matter and
antimatter come together
they annihilate each other
exploding in a cataclysmic shower of
heat and light so when a team of
researchers from multiple institutions
around the world actually found a form
of helium atoms
with both matter and anti-matter mixed
together they knew something big was
going on today we'll explore what
happened in this experiment and why it's
so important let's go into the
impossible
a new set of data hints that new physics
may be just around the corner
stick around and I'll explain how I'm
Brian Keating an experimental physicist
and cosmologist at UC San Diego I love
doing experiments in the lab and working
with the most brilliant people from
around the world and I like to bring to
you an experimentalist perspective so
what's going on with this anomalous
anti-matter
helium as you know is the second most
populous element in the universe making
up about 24 percent of the baryonic
ordinary matter in the universe it was
formed right after the big bang it was
formed from protons themselves made of
normal matter helium nucleus is an
atom's center with two protons and two
neutrons
the protons give it a positive charge to
counter balance and keep these two
positive like charges together you also
need neutrons whose strong force
opposites cause the proton and neutron
to stick together and allow two protons
to stick together now electrons in the
outer orbitals are the negatively
charged particles that give the overall
atom its neutral charge namely the two
positive charge in the proton plus the
two negative charge of the electron
gives a net charge of zero the neutrons
spoiler alert are electrically neutral
now the antimatter equivalent to the
proton is known as an antiproton it's
the opposite of a proton the opposite of
an electron is called a positron so
where a proton has positive charge an
anti-proton is negative charge where an
electron has a negative charge a
positron has a positive charge actually
one of my kids thinks we should have
called electrons negatrons I agree an
anti-helium atom would have to have two
antiprotons and two anti-electrons are
two positrons classically the
anti-proton is too heavy the anti-proton
would have a negative charge so it could
get attracted to protons so if you had a
anti-helium nucleus and an ordinary
helium nucleus they would come together
and Collide and annihilate each other
but an experiment recently discovered
that this doesn't always have to be the
case
how researchers discovered it relied on
the property that we've described on
this channel before we've discussed how
every element has a chemical fingerprint
its spectral bands a library of light
here's the different chemical signatures
the spectrum of colors reveals the
chemical composition what it's made of
its Elemental constituents including how
many protons and electrons it has the
light produced from a spectrum can
either be produced emitted or absorbed
and each one gives a unique chemical
assay or fingerprint of what the
composition is now the particles in
helium are incredibly chaotic
when normal pressure and say a balloon
that you get for a birthday party and so
they're always transferring energy
colliding with each other these atoms
and that causes the Spectrum to get more
blurry it's harder to resolve the
distinct chemical fingerprints
themselves when you have a higher
temperature say a room temperature gas
if you want to learn more about the
Spectrum you might want to cool down the
atoms to low temperatures such that the
Doppler broadening or the collisional
broadening is lessened in effect now
helium in addition to being the main
ingredient for the Macy's Thanksgiving
Day Parade balloons is also a gas that's
called a noble gas it is highly inert
doesn't react with itself or other
molecules
helium also has a very special property
called superfluidity which is the fluid
flow analogy of a superconductor a
superconductor when cooled below its
critical temperature has zero resistance
as I showed when I did this experiment
as shown here in my cosmology Clause but
what happens when you cool down helium
to the point of becoming a liquid it
will flow with zero viscosity or
resistance to fluid flow similar to the
way that a superconductor will have zero
resistance when cooled below its
critical temperature that will make the
spectral lines incredibly sharp but
recently researchers at CERN in Geneva
found that by firing antiprotons into
the mix of cold helium atoms that they
replaced some of the helium's electrons
with the negatively charged antiproton
they were able to stabilize this kind of
hybrid of ordinary nuclei of helium
helium 4 as it's known with replaced
electrons that were anti-particles of
the proton so that charge was conserved
you had two positive charges the two
protons two negative charges for the two
antiprotons antiprotons are then
negatively charged analog twins if you
like evil twins of protons so an
anti-proton can take on the charge
properties of an electron orbiting
around the helium nucleus in 2013 Soto
was working on an experiment on
antimatter
the group assembled a hybrid antimatter
matter atoms by firing the antiprotons
into liquid helium the result was a
small cohort of antiprotonic helium
atoms cool sounding name for a
fascinating type of new material but how
could it be wouldn't the protons
eventually suck in the antiprotons how
could you get them to capture each other
this could not be explained immediately
why the helium was so well behaved okay
so the researchers had to explain why
when they added antimatter protons into
a bath of helium with its ordinary
matter protons but rather than
annihilating each other they instead saw
the helium becoming more ordered less
collisionally broad on spectral lines
and this became more well behaved if you
will so let's break it down further it
was obvious that something was
preventing the helium atoms from
imploding on each other but what could
that be there were two explanations for
this either the hybrid matter
anti-matter helium atoms went through a
state of liquid to become what's called
a superfluid or the heavy antiprotons
themselves were more orderly behaved
than the electrons would be that they
were replacing they were heavier so
there would be less intrinsic kinetic
momentum from a proton moving with its
much more ponderous momentum than the
tiny little electrons now again
superfluids are fluids that flow with no
viscosity viscosity being the tendency
of fluids to cling onto themselves and
their containers and in so doing use up
a bunch of energy without actually
flowing smoothly more viscosity means it
flows less think of cold maple syrup
versus hot boiling water so what happens
when you reach zero viscosity and you
can get Behavior associated with
individual particles really Quantum
Behavior but on a macroscopic scale that
ordinarily couldn't happen at normal
temperatures in superfluidity you get
these strange looking phase diagrams and
the fluid flows without resistance and
it can actually leave and escape a
container that it's in almost as if it
has a mind of its own so even in a
gravitational field the fluid can float
right out of its container in the CERN
experiment the hybrid helium was already
cooled to the point of being a
superfluid so one explanation for what
happened in this experiment was that the
orderly movement of superfluid helium
somehow stopped it from colliding with
itself and thus minimize the amount of
antimatter matter collisions this both
caused the lack of annihilation between
matter and anti-matter but also allow
the spectral lines to be incredibly
sharp well defined and clean as the
researchers observed it to be another
theory is that the antiprotons are
simply more orderly than the electrons
they replaced as you know electrons are
incredibly small they're the second
lowest Mass elementary particle after
the ghostly neutrinos that may even have
zero mass for some of the three flavors
of neutrinos the electrons only have 0.5
Mev of energy using Einstein's famous E
equals m c squared scale to weigh them
the electrons energy is so small that we
measure its rest mass in energy the mass
of the electron is almost 2 000 times
lower than the mass of the proton or the
antiproton in hybrid helium researchers
made one anti-proton and one electron
orbiting the nucleus so again the net
charge was Zero the two protons in the
nucleus and the antiproton and the
electron both with negative charges
cancel out the positive charges so a
possibility for the hybrid helium being
so well behaved is that in liquid form
the heavier antiprotons settle in behind
the outermost electrons in the orbital
shells of helium they mask the charge of
the nucleus but they contribute less to
the interaction rate between an
anti-protonic form of helium with
ordinary non-anti-protonic or just
ordinary helium-4 atoms these
anti-protonic helium atoms much more
well-behaved than typical helium atoms
so now when I want to discipline my kids
all I have to say is can't you behave
more like your antiprotonic twin we
don't exactly know which one of these
explanations is the right one maybe it's
some hybrid of both of them or maybe
it's neither one researchers are still
looking for the answer as we speak but
one thing's for sure hybrid helium atom
stability means that we can get more
accurate measurements a lot better
spectroscopy involving materials that
are otherwise too disordered and chaotic
to work with by studying extreme matter
we learn about not only ordinary matter
in normal circumstances but we may also
learn about the origin and mass
mechanism of how the universe has the
structure that it does because according
to symmetry principles the early
Universe should have produced just as
much matter as antimatter therefore
annihilating itself in the very first
few nanoseconds after matter or
antimatter came into existence so we
shouldn't even be here I'm not even
supposed to be here today to ask the
question about why it exists or not so
it's a great mystery that matter
anti-matter asymmetry relies on
something called bariogenesis which
we'll talk about in future videos but
one thing's for sure studying the
properties of the smallest constituents
in the universe tells us about the
grandest cosmic scales possible this
investigation using tools of
spectroscopy and low temperature physics
tells us about Big Bang nucleosynthesis
formerly solely the purview of
astronomers and cosmologists working on
early Universe physics
now we won't be able to do this with any
type of atom for one thing helium is a
noble gas as I said and it can form a
superfluid not all gases can do that and
not all of them can be fired at with
anti-protons to form the simplest
possible specimens to study so up until
now we may do What these blurry
spectroscopic images and we have done
the best we can but now physicists at
CERN can look in a clean environment to
get more and more accurate data and
hopefully unveil the cosmic mystery of
how matter predominated over antimatter
and how we didn't all end up as a bath
of photons percolating through an empty
Universe physicists may be able to
construct all sorts of Novel materials
imagine decades from now we have an
anti-periodic table created by
techniques and studied by technology
such as that discussed in today's video
we may even someday be able to do
something with the Exotic particles that
are rarely discussed the pions cans and
other exotic Quark anti-core combination
maybe they have some hidden importance
that astronomers physicists and
Engineers are only just now beginning to
scratch the surface so if you like
learning about these fascinating new
breakthroughs and experimental physics
cosmology and particle physics subscribe
to the channel and click on this
playlist that I made just for you don't
forget to subscribe